hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the vice presidential debate kicks off
tonight in salt lake city utah
amid a contentious election season and a
global pandemic
is this year's vice presidential
face-off getting more attention
than previous years fox news
contributors moalithe and kristen saltas
anderson
share their insight to why the stakes
are so high for both vice president mike
pence
and democratic vice presidential nominee
senator kamala harris
president trump back in the white house
after a three-day hospitalization
for the coronavirus family and emergency
medical professional
and fox news contributor dr jeanette
nishwatt discusses the common
and experimental treatments mr trump
received and weighs in on covet 19
vaccination trials plus commentary by
guy benson host of the guy benson show
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm chris wallace i'm harris faulkner
i'm greg gutfeld
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday october 7th 2020 i'm lisa
brady
the one and only vice presidential
debate is tonight
but the focus may be someone who isn't
on stage
as the white house deals with an
outbreak one of the reasons why
vice president pence will be under such
scrutiny
is in part because the page has turned
to focus squarely on covid19
rather than on issues like the economy
i'm dave anthony
president trump got quite a few
treatments for the coronavirus
including one taken only by a very few
so far it's been tested
in just under 300 people and they did
not find any
serious side effects or complications it
was used as a compassionate use
in our president so in a sense he became
part of the trial
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the running mates only get one chance
and tonight
is that night vice president mike pence
and senator kamala harris will debate in
salt lake city moderated by usa today's
longtime washington bureau chief susan
page and with plexiglass between them on
stage
one of the safety measures ramped up
after the white house outbreak of
coronavirus which was still expanding
tuesday night
but pence has continued to test negative
and has been cleared by the cdc
to take part in the debate this pandemic
is not a red state or blue state issue
speaking in gettysburg pennsylvania on
tuesday joe biden said the pandemic
affects all of us will take anyone's
life it's a virus
it's not a political weapon using the
civil war battlefield as a backdrop to
talk about the cost of division
and calling on americans to come
together for healing
senator harris has mainly been doing her
own events including an online
fundraiser last weekend
with former president barack obama when
we vote
things change things get better
but tonight's debate is likely to focus
often
on someone who isn't on stage nobody
that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk
there's a danger but that's okay and now
i'm better as democrats accuse the
president of putting others at risk
with how he's handled both the pandemic
and his own case of the virus
senator harris's task
is simple keep the spotlight on
covid and on the administration's
response
mo olathe is the founding executive
director of georgetown university's
institute of politics and public service
and a fox news contributor
and this isn't uh you know just a debate
between the two campaigns top
surrogates the vice president was tasked
with heading up the administration's
coveted response he's the chair
of the covet task force and so she's
going to be able to connect him
to the president to a
federal response that overwhelmingly
polling shows people disapprove of
that's her task
the vice president has a tougher task he
wants to keep the conversation focused
on anything
but covet this is not a winning issue
for the administration this is not a
winning issue for the trump campaign
what about questions that harris might
face
about not being on the same page with
joe biden on every issue
she's been portrayed at least as
um you know by republicans as being much
more to the left than he is
um and you know does that put her
in a tough spot i mean does it matter if
she's not
a hundred percent in line with joe biden
on every issue
no she's she's his top surrogate
i don't think you're going to hear her
deviate much from where joe biden is
on the issues because he's the
presidential candidate
um but i think if the vice look for
for months now ever since the day
joe biden tapped her to be his running
mate republicans have been trying that
argument
and it hasn't moved the needle at all
they've been using it day in and day out
it was a big
core of their convention message the
president tried to use it in the debate
against joe biden last week and it
hasn't
moved the needle at all do you think
that senator harris needs to give an
answer
or joe biden for that matter on the
packing the court
question do you think it matters at all
to any voters i don't think it's an
issue that a lot of voters are thinking
about
except for the most energized voters in
either base
um but i think joe biden's strategy
on this is a smart one he wants to keep
the conversation
away from process when it comes to the
supreme court
and keep it focused on impact which is
why you haven't seen
um contrary to what i think a lot of
people's initial
expectation was you haven't seen the
the campaign focus on the perceived
hypocrisy
of senate republicans to move forward
with
the supreme court nomination uh after
four years ago refusing to even give
mayor garland
a hearing right you don't hear them talk
about the hypocrisy of that
what you hear them talk about is how in
the middle of a pandemic
this white house and this senate are
trying to ram
through a vote on the supreme court
to help overturn the affordable care act
they're trying to focus
on the substance as opposed to the
process
and they they all know that the more
they get sucked into a process
conversation the less their people are
gonna tune in to
the the real world implications
one last thing mo in you know in the
aftermath of
that very chaotic first presidential
debate
how much of a contrast are you expecting
wednesday night you think the com the
tone will be very different
yeah i do think the tone will be very
different i think look
they're both tough competitors both
senator and vice president pence they
both
are skilled debaters kamala harris
is known for being a very effective
prosecutor she's very effective as a
member of the
judiciary committee mike pence by all
indications won the vice presidential
debate four years ago
but they also come in with a very
different style and tone
and so i think it may be edgy
at times and you'll see a lot of sharp
elbows being thrown
but i don't think you're going to see
the same kind of circus i think they
both will have a little bit more respect
for the process than
the president did last week
republican pollster and fox news
contributor kristen soltis anderson
is also expecting a different tone mike
pence and donald trump
while they agree on many issues have
very different temperaments
trump has always been more bombastic
more of
a fighter more combative while mike
pence is much more laid back
much more uh reserved in his tone so i
expect for that reason alone
that the overall sense we will get from
the debate will be a little more sedate
than what we saw
between former vice president joe biden
and president trump
is pence under more pressure than he
maybe would have been because
of the president's debate performance i
think one of the reasons why
vice president pence will be under such
scrutiny
is in part because the page has turned
to focus squarely on covid19
rather than on issues like the economy
and with vice president pence as the
head of the president's coronavirus task
force
that means that he's going to be under
extreme pressure to answer tough
questions about our nation's response to
the virus
especially considering that it has made
it's all the way to the door of the
white house
what about trying to turn you know the
conversation to other issues i mean
we don't know exactly what the other
questions are going to be about
um but do you think he'll try to attack
senator kamala harris at all for
instance on the fact that she's
considered more liberal than
joe biden and you know do you think
pence will try to call her out
i expect the trump campaign to try very
hard to get kamala harris
to take a position that is to the left
of where joe biden has stated his
position is
whether it's on issues like defunding
the police on issues like the green new
deal on issues like health care
things where during the primary debate
she may have been to the left of joe
biden
truly republicans would like to run
against a very progressive far-left
candidate
and they've had a little bit of trouble
nailing joe biden down
into that kind of stereotype but kamala
harris does have a record that is
more that lends itself more effectively
to that strategy
so i expect pence to try to use this
opportunity
to get harris to say something or do
something that puts her far to the left
of where joe biden is
and that makes it easier for the trump
campaign to make the case
that the biden harris ticket is to the
left of where the mainstream of america
is
how much of an opportunity is this
though really
i mean are voters paying attention to
this at all especially given that
at this point two more presidential
debates are still scheduled
the reality is that vice presidential
debates usually have extremely
little effect on what is happening with
regards to people's choice at the top of
the ticket
and i think that's likely to be the case
here as well i don't expect
nearly the fireworks that we saw from
the debate between biden and trump
and so i expect this to be a much more
sedate affair with much
less of an effect on people's votes now
i'd add one caveat to that
which is that joe biden if he is elected
will be 78 years old when he takes
office
uh and donald trump 74 years old
both of them you could say may have
health concerns it's very important to
make sure you have a vice president
who could take the reins if heaven
forbid something were to happen
and so because of the age and health
questions around both of the candidates
for president
that's one reason why perhaps this time
around the vice presidential question
is a little more important than it might
otherwise be
and i guess there's the potential for it
to be not as
sedate and affair as some people might
think i mean if kamala harris decides to
go after mike pence
on the response to coronavirus for
instance the way she went after joe
biden
when they were competing against each
other in the primaries
um you know maybe it could it could
actually get very heated
i think kamala harris is very likely to
go after pence
both on the issue of kovid 19 as well as
going after him on the supreme court
pick of course mike pence is very
associated
with the socially conservative wing of
the republican party and that's an area
where democrats feel like they have
the potential for the upper hand that on
some of these issues like lgbt rights
they feel like they are more in line
with where the mainstream of america is
so i expect kamala harris to go after
mike pence on some of those issues
in particular um i do however think that
she is
unlikely to do anything terribly risky
right now with the biden campaign being
in the lead in most of the major polls
that we've seen
they are in the position where they want
to do as little as possible to change
this race they want to keep things
exactly as they are
as long as they can what do you think is
the number one
mistake for mike pence to avoid and for
kamala harris to avoid
i think the number one mistake for
harris to avoid is letting herself get
pulled into saying things
that will make it easier to peg the
biden harris ticket as far to the left
kamala harris needs to avoid giving any
ammunition to the trump campaign to make
the case that joe biden is actually very
far to the left a socialist etc
and because her record is further to the
left than bidens is
she presents that risk for pence what he
needs to do is make sure that he can
capably handle the questions on kovit
19. because that issue is such a
weakness for the trump campaign at this
point
he as the chair of that task force needs
to be ready
to rebut any arguments that they think
are unfair
and to try to make the case as best as
he can for the president's job at
tackling this virus
republican pollster kristen soltis
anderson
thank you very much for your time thank
you for having me
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
president trump remains inside the white
house
still recovering from his coronavirus
infection he tweeted a lot the day after
his release from walter reed medical
center including
that he's feeling great similar to what
he said in the video put out right after
his return
home on monday night i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago his doctor gave
a quick update
tuesday that the president is doing
extremely well not showing
any symptoms he was given multiple
treatments including an experimental one
which has been described as
unprecedented care
for a covid patient the only thing that
he had that was an
additional to what other people did not
have is regeneron
dr jeannette neshawt is a fox news
medical contributor
everything else is commonly used for
everyone else that everyone
has access to if they need for example
rembessevier the dexamethasone which is
a steroid that i use all the time
then we have blood thinners like aspirin
then zinc
vitamin d pepsid all of that stuff is
over the counter
so all of us have access to all of that
the only thing that he got that was
slightly different is regeneron which is
the cocktail of antibodies
but what's similar to that if you recall
is the convalescent plasma
so if you're in the hospital and your
doctor thinks you need antibody therapy
then they will use what's called called
convalescent plasma which is
antibody from another person regeneron
is just
artificially synthetically made
antibodies convalescent plasma is just
from another person
this particular treatment you said there
that it's synthetic
is this fda approved everybody gets this
did he get anything that others might
not try
like at all sure so right so regeneron
there um it's two monoclonal antibodies
in one and they are
actually looking to seek emergency use
authorization that's one aspect of it
but then
you know they have to also go through
the trials and the tests
to make sure that it is safe without any
of significant side effects so far it's
been tested
in just under 300 people and they did
not find any
serious side effects or complications it
was used as a compassionate use
um in in our president so in a sense
he became part of the trial okay
as a doctor would you be a little wary
of that if you were his doctor would you
be wary of giving
the president something that has not
been approved yet and only a few hundred
people had tried it
so you have to look at the risks and the
benefits and out of several hundred
people that are in the trial there have
been no significant
um or deadly complications or side
effects so that's reassuring to me
his team of doctors who are the best
doctors in the world
evaluated the data that exists and saw
that
if anything it just would not be of any
help to the president but would not
result in any
harm to the president we have to also
remember the president is under close
monitoring and observation with a team
of doctors
infectious disease specialist
pulmonologist internist
um every expert under the sun that
exists is looking after him
and collectively making a decision to
take care of him and rightfully so
that's what we would want for our
president rem de severe
that treatment what what does it do
yeah this is such a fascinating drug and
i'm so intrigued by it
so this is actually an antiviral
medication
that was tried to and tested to treat
ebola patients
what this drug does is um see the
the the covenant virus is an rna virus
that's made of
four bases four components remdesa fear
inserts itself as one of those
components
to short circuit and put a kink in the
replication
of that virus so rendezvous sneaks
itself in there
pretending it's one of those four
components and it blocks the virus from
replicating because when it realizes oh
what's going on here that the virus
stops replicating so it's really a
fascinating drug
that i believe is useful it's been
shown in studies to reduce
hospitalization duration by about four
days
and can help reduce mortality rate by
about 11
i think is what the data the most recent
data showed well that is very
interesting now what does this uh
what does that the steroid do the
dexamethasone which you said you've been
using
you know before yeah this is you know um
i don't know why uh people seem to think
that this is a
powerful drug this is a very common
steroid
i use it all the time and it's not just
used for for coronavirus
you can use it for allergic reactions or
rash or
swelling it's a steroid that's used to
reduce
inflammation a common drug is just going
to be used
short term minimal side effects and
people tend to do really well from it to
me it's like one of those miracle drugs
like
insulin if you will works really well
can can make a huge difference
now you might have seen this some of the
president's critics were saying that
he was on that and he was all roided up
what does it does does is there actually
anything to that i mean
do those does a drug like that do
anything
does it change your mood does it give
you a different feeling
yeah that's ridiculous that he's to say
something like that that he's all
avoided up
he's not taking anabolic steroids to
like a like a bodybuilder weightlifter
steroids help reduce inflammation what
does uh zinc do what do the vitamins do
yeah so vitamin d that's a really strong
and you know
immune system uh medica vitamin that
helps boost your immune system
helps strengthen it just like all the
other
vitamins out there you've heard of
vitamin c vitamin b12
it really helps to strengthen and boost
your immune system so that it can
function at
its maximum capacity zinc again
zinc i have been recommending zinc to my
patients more than just for coronavirus
zinc has been proven to help fight viral
replication
uh i've tell i've been telling patients
for years you know around especially
around
influenza season take some zinc there's
so many different types
there's the throat lozengers there's
coldies zycam whatever
any brand you want um that can help if
you start it
early um it can help fight the virus
from replicating and
it's a it's one that's used very
commonly again not just for tornavirus
but
can be used for many types of viral
infections back to that video president
trump put out on monday night
he also said this about the coronavirus
don't
let it dominate you don't be afraid of
it
you're going to beat it and he said he's
essentially leading by example get out
there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
he also tweeted many people die from the
flu every year despite the vaccine
are we going to close down our country
no
adding we've learned to live with it
just like we are learning to live with
covet and then he claimed
in many populations it is far less
lethal
twitter then masked that post for
spreading misleading and potentially
harmful information
house speaker nancy pelosi says the
president is being frivolous
dangerous his democratic challenger joe
biden said people
should be afraid for family and
co-workers which is why we wear masks
now dr neshowat has been treating covid
patients since the pandemic
started what does she think i don't
think we should be fearful i don't think
we should panic i think what we need to
do is take precaution not let our
guard down you know we saw thousands of
americans over the holidays memorial day
weekend um you know fourth of july
out and about large crowds parties close
contact
not wearing their mask not taking
protective measures i think it's
just a matter of staying uh you know
protect yourself
protect your loved ones be smart know
your risk
yes it can it is a scary virus it can
kill and affect anyone
the good news is though it's important
let's look at the facts
the facts are that the mortality rate is
low and
if you're in a higher risk category for
example
if you're older with diabetes or heart
disease or lung disease or kidney
disease
then you are at a higher risk so i think
it's just important
to remember to protect yourself know
your risk and adhere to the cdc
guidelines
and do the best you can until we have a
vaccine that's hopefully just
a few months away the vaccines that are
being
worked on this a bunch of them when they
come out
will you be ready to administer them are
you going to be worried if they were
rushed through a process
i will not be worried i'm ready to
administer them um we're going to
actually be
distributing them here in new york as
long as they go
through the phase trials the phase one
phase two phase three
the data shows that they're safe and
effective there's no
safety shortcuts that are being taken um
the only
shortcut that's being taken is the fact
that the vaccines are being manufactured
and prepared for distribution while they
are being tested
so if any um risk is being taken it's
just a financial risk
of uh you know are we um wasting all
this
vaccine and if it turns out when the
data comes out that
it has to be um scratched but um
this these vaccines that are being
tested are
going to be monitored and reviewed by
the fda and also by
a separate entity and have to be
reviewed by the
data safety monitoring board as well so
i feel confident once it's approved by
the fda it is approved
those are scientists and doctors that
are held to the highest ethical
and scientific standards that exist and
will not put
americans at risk the cdc has said again
the coronavirus can spread indoors it
can spread more than six feet through
the air
especially in these poorly ventilated or
enclosed spaces
you as a doctor you've been dealing with
this for months are there places you
will not go do you still think people
should be careful when they go out
when you're outdoors i'm not as
concerned as indoors but
yes you know the cdc is all they've been
a little bit back and forth with this
it's actually not new yes of course
how how is the virus gonna go from one
person to another
whether you're coughing sneezing talking
it's gonna get into the air
from the air into another person's
mucous membranes whether it's
your eyes your nose or your throat yes i
am i'm very careful i will not enter a
closed
space that's crowded if there's not good
ventilation or filtration because
i you know as a physician i i really
need to be very careful because i have a
duty and obligation responsibility
to take care of patients in the
community so um
i always try to take precautions um i
have
i was out of state once there was a
restaurant that was
opened at limited capacity 25
so i was in there with my family and it
felt like it was empty
and i felt safe but probably more than
25
or 50 percent i would not go in there
it's not worth the risk i would just
cook at home or order take out but the
best thing to do
is if you're going to be around people
if you're going to
attend any sort of event make sure it's
outdoors and try to
keep a good distance between you and
others just to protect yourself
it's very easy to forget about it to let
your guard down or to think
um well you look fine you sound fine so
you must not be a carrier but that's not
the case
many people can have it and have no
symptoms or very mild symptoms
dr jeanette neshwa fox news medical
contributor thank you so much for
joining us
thank you it's my pleasure have a
wonderful day stay safe and get your flu
[Music]
shot
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
is listening to fox news subscribe to
this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your fox news commentary
guy benson what's on your mind
in light of president trump's positive
diagnosis on covid
and three republican senators testing
positive for the disease
senate democrats are demanding that the
supreme court
confirmation process for amy coney
barrett be delayed they argue that the
hearings must be held
in person and therefore cannot start on
time but that's a bogus argument
born out of politics and advanced for
the sole purpose
of running out the clock the senate
judiciary committee
has held more than twenty confirmation
hearings for lower court judges
were at least part of the participation
has been virtual
that's been the case for months over the
course of this pandemic it is completely
acceptable
for senators to ask questions of the
nominee and get responses
in a thorough and thoughtful way even if
some of that questioning is done
over video republicans must be safe be
smart
keep calm carry on and confirm judge
barrett
this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes